[Music]
hi guys I'm Jamie Lee from The Pete home
show and I'm here at the 30th annual
Breeders Cup at the Santa Anita
racetrack I have my frilly hat I have my
sundress I have some pearls ready to
experience this I know nothing about
horse racing but I'm here to soak up the
[Music]
culture what brings you here well you
know I or may not have been to the races
before I was bit by a pony at 3 years
old and I was bit for life were you
really bit by a pony oh yeah yeah and
that didn't make you hate the pony or
the breed no no like my men same thing I
keep coming back from more ooh Charlotte
you nasty girl horses horses horses
horses
ooh hey how are you feeling okay oh he
has a little bit of on his
hoof ooh leather pants not bad jockey
not bad what is the Breeders Cup break
it down for us okay the Breeders Cup
basically brings all the horses in the
world together for a two-day period and
they race over certain distances as a
breeder you have to pay in to get your
horse entered in the race and that
creates the uh the pool of prize money
what's the most money you've ever bet on
a horse 400 million
wa that's a lot to Sam no I like to bail
on the horses that have good names but
some of them have crazy names some of
them are just like tour guide there's
some cool names in this Breeders Cup
game on dude that's a cool that feels
like a first draft to me Kenny mucho
Macho Man's a pretty cool name that one
I
[Music]
like so um what this is my first
Breeders Cup you guys what do you think
I should do today just have fun and this
is the rest of my day bet a little make
a little look at the Magnificent animals
you got this bud you got
this you're my guy you're my guy and get
down tonight
I can get used to
this come
on come
[Music]
on who are we rooting for We are rooting
for the Fugue number seven come on seven
go
[Music]
go oh my God oh my God oh my
God
go do it no oh what what
[Applause]
the that was an emotional roller coaster
Mondo that was an emotional roller
coaster we had it and we blew it at the
end I'm so
upset God I don't even know who I was
rooting for and I feel
[Music]
hurt
can we sing a quick little song about
horses you can
hores
race
here keep your day
job